what is going on everyone welcome to
part 13 of our finance with Python
tutorial series using kwang-ho pin and
zipline in this tutorial we're going to
be talking about building on top of this
kind of long short strategy that we are
working on so just to revisit that again
we've got our the symbols that were
interested in here are the spider ETFs
for all you know basically this main
major sectors and then in our handle
data
we're just trading moving average
crossovers so some people seem still
confused about what like even just a
moving averages so I went ahead and
recorded those down at the bottom along
with leverage you should probably always
record leverage it's so easy to over
leverage your accounts so I've started
recording it based on everything I write
now so coming over here I went ahead and
ran the strategy here and so here's the
results that we got you've already seen
this but then we can see here the moving
averages so the way that's working is
you've got a moving average it's quick
and one that's slow and so the quick
moving average it's basically a moving
average is just a moving window of
average prices okay so a 20-day moving
average today would be today's price
plus 19 days prices ago put those
together create an average good we do
the exact same thing tomorrow and the
next day in the next day so what kind of
smoothes out price a little bit when you
do that so you can even see that here
that as price starts going up here you
know following the S&P 500 you can see
that indeed the moving averages are
going up up up and then as this starts
to fall the quicker moving average
starts to react and then the slower one
just takes a while so anyway what we're
doing is as this shorter this kind of
bluish moving average when it's below
the longer moving average ma2 we're in
short mode so we're basically shorting
all these all those tickers and then
when it's above we're going long or
we're just we're buying them and when
you go short basically what you've done
is you've sold this you've sold that
ticker and basically you've sold it with
the intention to buy it back later so it
allows you to borrow it from somebody
else
you
sell their shares and then later on you
buy him back in the hope is that you buy
him back at a cheaper price given back
to that person and you've made money so
anyways that's the strategy that we're
going to be working on and I've been
live testing it since guess the 19th or
the 18th or I guess actually the 17th so
we started it on the 17th and actually
we've lost money but we're still we're
pretty well beating the market at the
moment we're doing like four times
better through the market right now this
has been kind of slipping but anyway
there's that that's been running and
then I also wanted to go ahead and bring
up the latest news from quanto peon they
just updated this a couple days ago
about the contest rules for July which
it is right now
just today is July 1st for me and
basically they're the update here is
that they want everyone to be hedged
instead of kind of more of like a
high-risk buy one one company kind of
situation where you can blow up so I
also want to go ahead and stress and
kind of talk in this tutorial a little
bit about what are hedge funds like what
actually is a hedge fund and because I
think a lot of people have a
misconception about how the world of
finance works so a lot of people want to
come into finance and they look at maybe
a strategy like this and the only thing
they ever care about is did we beat the
market yes or no and like that's the
only thing people care and then maybe
they'll bring in alpha and beta and some
Sharpe and they'll be like do we beat
the market with good alpha beta and
Sharpe let's say and if you did beat the
market great if you didn't then what the
heck are you doing here
right and actually that's not really the
case so a lot of people come to the
field of Finance with a little bit of
bias because most people playing in the
world of finance are relatively poor
compared to the big institutions that
are hedge funds okay so most people
aren't billionaire hedge fund managers
right they are your typical person who's
trading with maybe 25,000 to $100,000
account and that's it so that kind of
person the kind of person who has a 25
to $100,000
what do they want right well that person
probably wants to see high risk high
yield they want to see a good good
amount of returns they're not gonna be
happy with like you know 5% returns a
year or 10% a year or something like
that they want more but then kind of try
to put yourself in the shoes of somebody
who has maybe twenty five billion
dollars what would you want would you
want your twenty five billion in a
high-risk high-yield situation or are
you trying to protect your assets at
that point well most billionaires
they're engaged in protecting assets
that's what they want to do so the
reason why we have these billionaire
hedge fund managers is or billion dollar
hedge fund managers I should say is what
they do typically I mean the definition
of a hedge fund is hedge fund okay
nowadays hedge fund has been kind of
skewed to mean a lot of stuff but a
hedge fund traditionally is a fund that
hedges the market and now what does that
mean
well here's a perfect example of us
hedging the market where the market
drops we go up right and almost it's a
zero-sum right it's we lost a little bit
of money there but it was almost a zero
sum so ideally a hedge fund what it's
gonna do is it's gonna take the risk out
of being in the market so consider like
the the housing crisis which was
basically like right here where we hedge
into the housing crisis um the the
problem with the housing crisis is over
the period of a few months people worth
half of what they were worth initially
so not only is it billionaires with
maybe large estates that they're trying
to manage and keep its also companies so
companies are also sometimes the biggest
supporters of hedge funds so a good
example of companies or just people that
kind of have started up with these hedge
funds would be like the entire options
market so the idea of the options market
is you've got your farmers this is
actually this is really basic because
nowadays farmers don't even own their
livestock usually but you've got a
farmer and let's say this say this farm
is growing corn okay
but the problem is corn takes so much
time to grow and when it's time to sell
that corn it's time to sell that corn
just sit around and wait a few months
for price to be where we want to be to
sell our corn we kind of need to sell
that corn quick and so the options
market came around because farmers there
they're a farmers profit margin is not
very big so a farmer can't hope right
for price to be just perfect when it
comes time for them to actually move
their bushels of corn let's say so the
options market comes around and so
mister finance comes to the farmer and
says hey I would like to sign a contract
with you that's basically gonna say I
will buy this corn from you on this date
for this price so cool the farmers happy
because he knows exactly how much money
he's gonna make per bushel of corn let's
say and and then from that moment on
that mr. finance goes and starts trading
these little options papers basically
these little contracts that say I'm
gonna buy this for this much money on
this day and they just they play that
game for a while and what that does is
it smoothes out the market but who's it
smoothing it out for farmer guy okay so
other people are trying to make money
but at the end of the day the purpose of
this all of this nonsense is so the
farmer can reliably have his income okay
so while that's a super basic example
there are also massive companies that
engage in this exact same process so
think about like the meat industry okay
so one of the one example of this would
be like the Cargill right so they're
they're involved in the meat market and
the meat industry and so what does
Cargill do well Cargill is dependent on
returns and what companies like this are
gonna do is they're gonna hedge against
the market of meat okay so they've got
traitors and these traders their job
isn't to make money in the meat market
that's not their job their job is to
smooth out the fluctuations in the meat
market so no longer are we working for
trader Joe we're working for you know
big big man Cargill over here but the
same kind of purpose its to smooth out
the market right this is asset
protection and so when we look at quanto
pian what they're trying to do is
protect assets okay so the hedge fund of
quanto pian
least to me is appearing to their goal
is not necessarily to beat the market
that's not what they're trying to do at
at least one toe peon they're trying to
be more of a traditional hedge fund to
the point where they're trying to cancel
out market risk so just because you make
a strategy on quanto pian it's not so
much whether or not you beat the market
they want low beta they want hedge
that's basically it so for that reason
even though I made this strategy before
this even came out
that's just more of like my belief but
luckily it's happened to be the case
that this is also their belief and so
we're able to kind of continue on that
would have stunk if they changed to
something else I suppose but anyway
they're looking for people that are
hedging algorithms so the basic
definition of the hedge would be an
algorithm that both will go long and
short and that's basically required to
do so anyways I just wanted to get that
out as far as what actually goes on in
the world of Finance so it's not all
about just making big money it's it's
about smoothing out it's about asset
protection a lot of times there's
probably more jobs out there to protect
people's assets than there are jobs out
there or at least there's probably
there's probably more money I suppose
like on the line to protect assets then
there is money to like grow assets right
like everybody wants you to make money
like your quanto peon strategy has to
earn money right because otherwise we'd
be in the market but almost everybody
compares their earnings say to the S&P
500 when really you probably should
compare your earnings to like I don't
know
bonds or something like the 10-year bond
yield or something like this like that's
what you should be comparing to because
people are looking for multiple places
to put their money so also before I
close this out like a lot of people that
are invested in hedge funds that's not
their sole investment okay so the people
that are gonna fund quanto peon chances
are that's not their only investment
they've probably got money in all kinds
of places
quanto peon the goal of quanto peon
isn't to beat the market right because
though the investors don't care about
that they already have money in the
market right
they're invested in the sp500 let's say
they're probably in some mutual funds
they're probably in some other hedge
funds and their pride just like sitting
in some ETFs and stuff like this so
they're going to have a diverse
portfolio so they're not only focused on
like one strategy so just keep that in
mind there's a lot of options out there
in the world besides beating the market
if you can smooth out the market like if
you could find a way to have a nice
smooth return with very little drawdown
that would be probably way more valuable
than a strategy with a lot of
fluctuation yet it say doubles the
market so keep these things in mind as
we kind of go through but this one kind
of rant I didn't plan to spend this much
time on like one video talking about
hedge funds but it's really important
that people understand what's going on
in the field of Finance because a lot of
people are interested in finance but
they kind of have this misconception
about like what's the actual goal and
some people want to be maybe hired on as
a hedge fund manager but they don't even
understand the purpose of the hedge fund
that they're trying to get hired on to
so it's important that we understand
these things as we as we move forward so
anyways what we're going to be doing in
the next tutorial is we're going to be
returning to this original kind of long
short strategy and I'm going to show you
guys how we can bring in machine
learning
so with Python machine learning is as
close to plug-and-play
as possible it's really simple so I want
to show you guys how we can incorporate
machine learning into quanto peein we're
not gonna be talking about the
fundamentals of machine learning I'll
try to point you in the right direction
for that because you'll need that if
you're going to use machine learning but
I want to show you at least tying in
machine learning is really quick and
really easy really in Python but it just
as easy on quant opium so that's what
we'll start doing in the next tutorial
so stay tuned for that if you guys have
any questions or comments on this
tutorial or really anything leading up
into this point please feel free to
leave them below otherwise as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support and subscriptions until next
time